6 heures du matin chez christian aid à
chantilly les écuries reprenne vie peu à
peu on prépare le premier lot de chevaux
pour l'entraînement celui de trêve
le rituel est immuable elle a besoin de
marcher pour fait choper
total a en main à la personne pour le
dos du coup à la pomme à l'auto sa lutte
armée de sochaux plus facilement et
après leur entrée ils vont là c'est laid
comme ça l asra les muscles seront
chauds et on attend les ordres pour
sortir et après on se retrouve tous
devant la dent dans les roues des trêves
rentre on sort c'est la crac la crac
la championne la star trêve quoi un pur
sang anglais pouliche de légende cheval
exceptionnel dont le quotidien est réglé
comme du papier à musique
les chevaux ont besoin de routine et
envol entraîneur qu'elle a écrit keith
aide sait pertinemment que pour les
garder concentrés on ne doit surtout pas
changer leurs habitudes dans les chevaux
y connaissent bien tous ils ont la
mémoire ils savent très bien que n'ont
pu aller très calme même si comme salle
de la tête
elle a l'air là c'est parce que leader
et marchent pas assez vite s'ils sont
leaders marché un peu plus vite elle
serait elle dans son rythme mais là l
epad en soirée alors on la retient tout
le temps voyez ce regard concentré
christiane head c'est avant tout un oeil
acéré
bonjour il est un rêve d'enfant ou là
ces chevaux on les voit tous les jours
et tous les jours il nous en apprennent
vous apprennent quelque chose parce que
dans leur physique qui changent alors
nous c'est notre métier donc on les voit
assez logique que vous les voyez pas de
la même façon nous c'est une façon de
nous parler en réalité on peut la voir
plus ré plus ne plus raide que ça là
elle est bien
pour elle c'est pas assez rapide elle
aime aller beaucoup plus vite
fin de l'entraînement et retour au box
christiane head a eu deux mille huit
cents chevaux entre les mains depuis
qu'elle s'est installée en 1977 elle en
a 80 ans ce moment et elle les connaît
tous nos entraîneurs on aime bien mais
qu on n'est pas du tout aucune brutalité
au contraire plus doit se faire dans le
calme et doit se faire
tallinn est tout seul ils n'ont pas levé
le nez elle est très contente 2008 100
chevaux à l'entraînement n'est pas un
seul comme trêve ça vite elle a montré
qu'elle était meilleure que les autres
chevaux et que rien ne pouvait à la
maison aller avec elle alors après il
fallait la comparer avec ceux des autres
écuries mais quand elle a débuté sa
carte pour ce gala gagner et elle a
montré cette accélération qui absolument
c'est dévastateur et le 13 septembre
trêve à 5 ans a encore montré qu'elle
était la plus rapide lors du prix
vermeille ce qui était de très bonne
augure pour son troisième arc de
triomphe
la suite on la connaît la pouliche a été
battu dans l'arc par des mâles de 3 ans
metref qui finit 4e n'a vraiment pas à
rougir de sa course par la police tant
par la grande porte
c'est vrai que des fois un petit peu on
va préférer tellement rentrer dans
l'histoire
les quoi est fabuleux ça reste une belle
histoire
et puis c'est la petite soeur car il a
une petite soeur prometteuse que nous
vous présenterons demain